en france et le dossier sensible du
gouvernement pour cette rentrée jean
pierre raffarin souhaite apporter de
nouveaux assouplissements à la loi des
35 heures mais apparemment en douceur le
ministre du travail va donc recevoir
tous les syndicats le premier à ouvrir
le bal
c'est françois chérèque pour la cfdt
sophie rolland et xavier roman plutôt
rassuré françois chérèque après sa
rencontre avec le ministre le
responsable de la cfdt a eu l'impression
que le gouvernement n'a pas envie de
bousculer la loi sur les 35 heures pour
lui ce nouveau des bols d'ailleurs
inutile on lui a demandé de mettre fin à
cette polémique stupide qui consiste à
se faire un psychodrame commence et les
faire en france sur la remise en cause
de la loi qui elle même a déjà été
modifié il ya quelques mois sans
attendre une révision de la loi
plusieurs patrons ont dès cet été remis
en cause leurs accords 35 heures chez
bosch par exemple les salariés ont
accepté de travailler 36 heures sans
compensation salariale pour éviter une
délocalisation en bretagne le volailler
doux imposé à ses salariés de renoncer à
leurs rtt sans augmentation de salaire
même chose chez cathy nerfs dans le
doubs est aujourd'hui le patronat met la
pression et réclament davantage de
liberté je trouve qu'on devrait se
passer de la loi donc il s'agit pas de
la supprimer ou pas la supprimer
il s'agit de dire que la loi est un
filet de sécurité lorsque la négociation
échoue mais chaque fois que les
entrepreneurs et leurs salariés peuvent
s'entendre eux mêmes au plus proche de
la réalité de leur entreprise
c'est un progrès social de son côté la
cgt parle de chantage à l'emploi et
compte bien demander au gouvernement
d'intervenir
nous allons donc demander au
gouvernement de faire un peu plus que de
s'en tenir à quelques propos de
condamnation il a la possibilité de
rendre ces pratiques illégales dans la
possibilité de les sanctionner y compris
financièrement et c'est la première des
choses que nous allons
demandez les consultations avec les
autres syndicats reprendront dès lundi
et continueront jusqu'au 7 septembre le
débat sur les 35 heures est à nouveau
lancé et il n'est pas près de se
refermer